how many points are in it at the moment
as this is being shot it's eight points
yeah that's what I'm saying that's what
I'm saying so say for example right if
we go and get look there's a lot of ifs
and buts and maybe if we go and get a
result against Brighton yeah and we go
and then beat you guys at Old Trafford
all of a sudden all of a sudden it's
five points now look at this let me just
let me just tell you this one thing
right there's a lot of good teams in the
Premier League and so far this season
man united have done brilliant to not
look great and beat the smaller clubs
when you've come up against big teams
yeah we get HED you've been be look I
think Chelsea have got a future you guys
got a future You Got Talented players
but I just think it's too soon for you
guys you know what I mean as much as
United visually on the eye it's not good
to watch it's it's hard to watch
sometimes United know how to get results
Chelsea at the on the other hand I just
don't see it in you guys and your
players to be able to go three wins four
wins five wins in a row you know what
I'm saying say I just don't see that in
your squad